this is the video in question first
shared with kou1 via the next door app I
see him making a m turn around in shock
iold Alfred Lewis spoke with me about
how he feels about it now you know I
just made a mistake and everybody makes
mistakes what people didn't see was that
I shook his hand after I gave the man a
hug how can we miss that is something we
cannot
verify that another man the video
getting punched and grabbed as far as
I'm concerned people like this deserve
attempted murder I was about to say you
any idea how many times people hit head
in the concrete we've had video of that
where a guy he got hit with the
skateboard hit his head on the concrete
now he he can't walk that would be the
part that the media would show you what
they didn't show you was afterwards I
sent the mother Tiff streets the vast
majority of black people like this kid
is a dumbass but there are enough that
it's alarming going oh man it's just
differences in culture well then that's
a bad culture I I love the victim
response